[Applause]
thank you so much for coming on the show
today
oh it's my pleasure my pleasure so nice
to see you
i have this strange feeling as if you've
never not
been on the scene and you've been a part
of these big sweeping movies i mean the
butler is such a big deal it broke all
those records it's such an
important true story you worked with
oprah winfrey
and she's an executive producer on your
new film
the water man what is it like working
with such a legend
you know my relationship with her began
with us playing mother and son
and that relationship sort of bled
beyond
being in front of the camera she she
just continued to be
a sort of mother figure in my life a
great
you know um source of advice for me
advocacy for me encouragement for me
we share a sensibility and um yeah she's
just been
one of my uh my life's greatest
blessings you know from
from being together in the butler she
was one of the main reasons
selma even happened it was when i asked
her to come on board as a producer
that that really sort of gained traction
and then in terms of the water man
it was something i went to her and told
her i was passionate about and she said
look i'm gonna do everything i can
to help you realize this dream i do feel
like when she
ordains things in any way as something
we're all supposed to pay attention to
we do
we want people to shine light on stories
history
of you know whether it's fiction or
non-fiction
stories i mean she started with the book
club
stories are so important
and you know i heard that et
was a film you saw very young
what may i ask did that film do for you
well i have to admit this is incredibly
surreal for me to be talking
to you about this because that film was
so
formative in my life um
it's super weird to be talking to you
about it and and that oprah is my friend
i mean
how weird is life um but anyway um it
was formative for me
you know i often say it's the first time
i actually saw on film
a family going through that very tough
thing of the father has left
the kids are having to deal with where's
daddy gone
the mother is having to deal with that
as well and then whoosh
the adventure and the fantasy begins and
spielberg
more than anyone you know has just done
that so brilliantly i managed to get my
film to him
and he watched the water man and wrote
back to me and said you're a fine
director and a really good storyteller
and i was just like oh my goodness life
is so weird
um but anyway um
it makes me so happy he'll be honest too
i i do believe like he is that kind of
person
yeah you know i have four kids now and
uh to get to share
these kind of stories with them is so
precious to me because i had to go
back to those films in order to share a
narrative like this to them so when
the waterman came along i thought gosh
this could be something like that
for a modern audience we actually have a
clip from um the waterman
and i was wondering if you could kick it
old school for us and help us set it up
okay is it is it a clip between me and
lonnie
guess what i'm about to surprise you
with it hold on
watch this okay if you had to choose
between a short life with a lot of love
in it
and a very long life with
no one love to love which one would you
choose
i would take a short life with your mom
in it
than a long one without her
me too
i i'm just so excited for this movie
okay
can i ask you another question i was
reading in
your um life story that
you had had a point where you thought
maybe you would follow in your father's
footsteps in life
and he had gotten married when he was 40
years old
um but you met the love of your life
when you were
what was the exact age we were 17 and 18
when we first met
okay and i was wondering
what would you say to someone who their
life surprised them much earlier than
they had planned
oh it's a it's a beautiful question
actually because as you say my dad
was my hero and so basically i was gonna
follow
in his footsteps and then life happened
i met
this woman and you know we became
friends initially and then i just got to
the point where i
couldn't imagine the rest of my life
without her in it and i thought
oh no it's gone and happened way earlier
than i thought it would
is it true that the morning after your
wedding
uh there was a towel
okay so i i am i am
anally tidy and
my my wife's name is jessica and she
grew up being called
messi jesse so you know we had a
beautiful wedding
we had our wedding night and it's the
next morning and my new
wife my brand new wife goes in the
shower she has a shower
she comes in and she takes off her towel
and she
throws it on the floor and presents
herself with all of her nakedness
and the first thing i did was go
i was looking at the towel
and she thought oh dear we may have a
problem here i love your love story with
your wife
so much and i just wanted to celebrate
[Music]
it